you like that Jimmy
all right Elon Musk still shaking things
up at Twitter and the Liberals can't
stand it the world's richest man is
trolling critics with new stay at work
merchandise following his discovery of
stay woke t-shirts at the company's
headquarters and the left is really not
gonna like this musk May release juicy
details of Twitter's internal
discussions that led to the censoring of
the hunter Biden laptop report which
says which he says is quote necessary to
restore public trust so I'll start with
you Jimmy if if he has this information
why is he playing games why is he you
know teasing in I'm gonna do a Twitter
poll just said we ought to know right oh
I do think it's coming uh but he's
probably just trying to hire a food
taster before he does because they are
out for this they hate it so much he has
it but why does he just do it uh I don't
know the answer to that I think there's
two things I think Elon Musk is well
intended but he has really embraced the
role of Twitter troll at the same time
like he is in the trenches on Twitter
like I'm like to the point that I'm like
get a life dude yeah like so much like
when I got a reply I was like all right
this is a little carried away now you
know what I'm saying it's been fun it's
been fun I know it hasn't been fun for
uh Jessica but Jessica I'm but I'm not
nearly as sensitive as you would think
uh Jesse okay not for Jessica to be on
Twitter because I see the crap that
people say to her listen I apologize for
most of it yes okay so let me ask you
this really quick so we know reportedly
when this stuff comes out we'll see what
we all suspect is happening which is
that you know liberal voices are
elevated conservative way voices are
turned down if you ask me you're in
politics you know you know as much as I
do that's an in-kind donation that's
illegal so do you think we should
investigate when when this information
comes out should we investigate and
prosecute uh those Executives but even
those employees who were involved in the
suppression of democrat candidates for
example or campaigns or republican
campaigns I don't I I guess you have to
see what happens there but I do know for
instance now it's funny that Elon Musk
owns Twitter we only talk about big Tech
being Twitter right that suddenly we've
gotten back and we don't mention the
fact that Facebook which is still pretty
popular that conservative media does
better than liberal media and we know
that to be the case well so I I'm just
saying I have never been afraid of
Hunter Biden's laptop I have not been
afraid of an investigation into these
things I think that the American public
knows what they think is a real
investigation what they think is a sham
investigation and they know also if they
think that whatever Hunter Biden which
we can all agree is not someone that you
would be voting for right if you were
running for any office is different than
his father so I have no idea
okay I get it okay okay
but if one is linked to the other then
it's significant but then we'll find
that out but at this particular moment
you just have a lot of videos right but
you know but we know that the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptops
no story affected the election of 2020.
that matters Joey that matters doesn't
it the suppression of that story matters
here's the hunter Biden is an absolute
turd of a human being okay but if his
father has been complicit in either the
business dealings or covering up for a
son that does matter because that is who
people have to vote for and Republicans
are not wrong for wanting to investigate
this because whether smoke there's fire
there's smoke everywhere but you're
talking about Elon Musk on Twitter if a
platform bans The Babylon B for
misinformation they're on the wrong
track and they have an agenda and I hope
he does expose it I don't hitch myself
to anybody's wagon there is no Messiah
there was one and that was a long time
ago I don't care if it's the president
United States Elon Musk Kanye West or
anybody else that says something radical
one day that I believe in because
they're going to say something tomorrow
that's going to put me in a corner so
don't praise Elon Musk don't praise
anybody find the principles you believe
in and reward the people that
consistently engage in them and if
that's what Elon Musk does now that's
great if I don't like or trust him
anymore today than I did before he
bought Twitter I don't like or trust
Twitter anymore today than I did before
he bought it well Dagan will go back to
the original question if Elon Musk has
the this information why doesn't he just
release it and if he does release it and
it shows this sort of complicity between
the federal government Democrats and and
Twitter is that prosecutable because
that isn't in kind donation to many
campaigns it change to 2020. with a
bigger issue would would be and this is
wild speculation is if there was any
contact between anyone in the federal
government and Twitter and they were
well that's a violation of the First
Amendment yes uh period but it it's not
like there's like a piece of paper that
was on elon's desk when he showed up at
Twitter and it's like oh well that's who
was involved in it it requires a huge
data dive and he's got other things on
his plate like keeping the you know
advertisers on board but I find it musk
is in favor of Greater freedom of speech
greater freedom of expression greater
transparency and the fact that liberal
journalists like Don Lemon and that
loser at the Washington Post are most
triggered by this kind of tells you
everything that you need to know it's
pathetic and embarrassing but it tells
you that they see their jobs as being
mouthpieces of the left and advancing
The Narrative opinion and world view of
the left-wing luniverse I just love it
and I I just I find that and by the way
where's the outrage and hand ringing and
self-reflection over accepting an
obvious lie about Hunter Biden's laptop
story about it being disinformation
right before a presidential election and
then silencing actual journalists who
broke the story I just love really
where's the Pearl collection I just love
that CBS has authenticated the story to
you yeah two years later isn't it
amazing they're on it it took him two
years to complete an investigation but
they can complete a Twitter boycott in
two days yes you know what I mean come
on man yeah it's laughable all right we
gotta go ahead climate change protesters
are getting even more crazy and it's
apparently fueling kids nightmares hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now